un gobierno que homenajea a la vieja
guardia talibán
el grupo definió un ejecutivo interino
encabezado por líderes históricos de la
formación y sin la participación de
mujeres ni de personas ajenas al
movimiento una de las grandes demandas
de la comunidad internacional
el portavoz talibán resaltó el carácter
provisorio del gobierno aunque no
especificó plazos del mandato ni que
seguir a la transición saha pariaman a
paul hombres del dios por primera vez se
preparó el terreno para la llegada de un
gobierno islámico fuerte nuestro país
necesita actividades integrales y
servicios en diversos campos para
abordar los derechos legales económicos
y sociales de las personas y prevenir
pérdidas arzak a vuelta asad serrat levy
el mulá hassan hay un será el nuevo
primer ministro se trata de uno de los
líderes menos conocidos del grupo
talibán aunque ha forjado su reputación
a la cabeza de la rak bari sur a máximo
consejo de liderazgo de la formación
uno de sus vicepresidentes será el mulá
abdul ghaní baradar cofundador del grupo
y líder de la delegación que firmó el
acuerdo con eeuu para el retiro de
tropas
un nuevo gobierno que ya enfrentaba
resistencias antes de iniciar cientos de
hombres y mujeres se movilizaron en
kabul en rechazo a los talibanes y el
vecino pakistán al que acusan de
interferir en los asuntos afganos los
talibanes intentaron dispersar las
protestas con disparos al aire
los talibanes son muy injustos y no son
humanos para nada no respetan nuestro
derecho a manifestar
vamos a defender nuestra sangre y
nuestras vidas vamos a defender nuestro
norte
mientras tanto crece la preocupación por
la situación económica y social la onu
alertó que los servicios básicos en el
país están colapsando y podría agravarse
la crisis alimentaria por la falta de
insumos